innovator disrupter Game Changer these
are the terms that typically pop up when
we think about Elon Musk how else would
you address the man who created Tesla
SpaceX and PayPal whether we want to be
inventive business owners or employees
many of us have a thing or two to learn
from this real-life Iron Man but
everyone has a skeleton in their closet
and we can't help but wonder about what
his secrets are to catch you up to speed
on the off chance that you don't exactly
know his backstory Elon Musk co-founded
the online payment Corporation PayPal
and in 2002 he established the rocket
and spacecraft manufacturer SpaceX he
contributed significantly to Tesla's
early funding and was named the company
CEO in 2008. Tesla produces electric
vehicles and batteries and in 2022 he
bought the social media platform Twitter
this leads us to our first point his
transparency is Just an Illusion being
very vocal about his moves is one thing
we know for sure about the richest man
in the world however the CEO who has the
most to say abruptly became quiet during
his Twitter purchase he also disclosed
the information in a way that let him
conceal the method of payment for the
share did he borrow money against his
Tesla stock to pay for the purchase as
he has done in the past to raise money
or did he purchase Twitter stock with
any of the proceeds from the recent sale
of his Tesla shares it was indeed a
baffling mystery it also showed us that
he's not as transparent as he markets
himself to be and knows when to keep
things unsaid and unheard people say he
talks and reveals a lot even more than
he's supposed to but the way we see it
it's all a ploy people love supposedly
genuine people people trust people that
they feel they know and Elon uses that
to his advantage today Elon is one of
the most influential people in finance
and because of his Fame he must obtain
the sec's approval before posting any
Financial tweets people actually base
decisions on his tweets which could lead
to a lot of Market ups and downs and he
cannot risk losing this influence he
creates from complaints people seem to
think that Elon picks world-class
solutions from the air when all he does
is look critically at problems and try
out Solutions until they work yes it
seems so easy when put plainly but
that's all there is to it however Elon
has an edge over a lot of people what
makes him stand out a simple fact that
he thinks outside the box when creating
these Solutions take traffic for example
most people complain about traffic not
Elon Musk musk looked for a solution
rather than whining about the issue this
led to the creation of the boring
company which aims to relieve traffic
congestion by building a network of
tunnels and that was quite the name
right he takes random shots until he
gets a hit many people complain about
Elon being haphazard in his methodology
but the way we see it there is a pattern
there's no doubt that he's a genius but
life is genuinely a game of numbers so
the more chances you take the more
likely you are to succeed this means
trying every idea you have in
approaching a solution until one works
to succeed not many people want to take
chances despite the calculated risk we
choose not to take it to avoid any
negative effects Elon doesn't have such
fears and that simple value keeps him
one step ahead the first three launches
of Elon SpaceX were unsuccessful and
there were production and design
concerns with Tesla he also put all 200
million dollars from the sale of zip2
and PayPal into SpaceX and Tesla which
did not get off to a great start
compared to us Elon Musk has taken
considerably more risks and that has
majorly contributed to his success he
funds new businesses with old businesses
on the subject of taking risks what many
people don't know is that you have to
believe in yourself or an idea enough to
risk something that you have already
built for the new Venture and this is
something Elon does often yet many
startups and entrepreneurs seem to be
unaware of this because it is difficult
for anyone to put the profits into a new
business this success secret is the one
that most entrepreneurs Overlook as we
mentioned earlier Elon Musk sold zip2
and PayPal to fund his investments in
SpaceX and Tesla to succeed as an
entrepreneur you must understand that
reinvesting income in expanding existing
Enterprises is very key the most notable
example of an entrepreneur that started
from scratch is Elon Musk he began
building and today he is the richest man
on earth however he leveraged on his
first successful Venture and built the
next and the next till he got to where
he is today he plans for success but
prepares to fail Elon Musk talks a big
game and when he fails have you noticed
that he bounces back a little too
quickly while some see him as cocky
daring and spontaneous it's a well-kept
secret that Elon is an avid planner it's
said that even his backup plans have
backup plans so even if he seems
Reckless he's ready with a plan for a
comeback and a new attempt at execution
there isn't a success crystal ball even
musk was unable to foresee the future of
Tesla Motors however he has emphasized
that if something is important enough
you should attempt it even if failure is
likely to resolve you should make every
attempt to pursue your dreams if you
care about them but be prepared in case
it doesn't work out at the same moment
if you have a backup plan in place it is
simpler to bounce back from a failure
and that's why it looks like he does it
all so effortlessly how he combines
social media and running his businesses
many people often wonder how Elon Musk
manages three businesses SpaceX Tesla
and neuralink has a lot of daily
responsibilities and still has time for
social media as we mentioned earlier his
social media presence and influence are
quite purposeful but how does he
efficiently manage to stay relevant and
get work done well a little known fact
is that he uses asynchronous
communication basically Elon favors
having conversations on his terms this
necessitates using asynchronous methods
of communication like email and SM Ms as
the norm by utilizing a mysterious email
address he also makes it difficult for
individuals outside his organization to
contact him he can then concentrate on
doing the actual work for his companies
he sends out emails to his entire
organization frequently with updates
advice on communicating company visions
and missions and tips for increasing
productivity so he takes care to
eliminate anything that is not thought
essential concentrating exclusively on
the most crucial matters and that's how
he does it all like a superhuman he
majorly relies on a constructive
feedback loop how does the richest man
alive know when he's on the right track
a constructive feedback loop apparently
it's crucial to have a feedback loop
where you're always thinking about what
you've done and how you could be doing
it better this helps keep you on the
right track and the best tip is to
always reflect on how you could improve
and probe your own assumptions you can
always improve therefore getting helpful
criticism can Aid in your development
negative input from though those who
have your best interests in mind might
also be carefully considered because
they can identify the weaknesses in your
development this process as simple as it
sounds goes a long way and if you're
wondering Elon seems largely unbothered
it's because he disregards any other
unfavorable comments after all you can
never learn anything from those who
don't know you really considering
negative criticism and seeking it out
especially from friends is hardly ever
done even though it is quite beneficial
his actions are not as mindless or
Reckless as people think it might seem
that Elon just makes random decisions
but we believe it's a rude with every
Reckless looking action people get
skeptical until he once again comes out
on top after being heavily
underestimated he might just be doing
this to over deliver or it might just
look this way to Outsiders but we can't
deny that despite how it may seem he
weighs his decisions carefully take the
Twitter purchase for example once more
did he buy Twitter on a whim we think
not let's look at the statistics
consider Apple or Google as examples of
ecosystems when you shop at Apple you
don't just purchase a phone after
purchasing the phone you must also
purchase the laptop iCloud services and
Apple TV with Google it's the same thing
there is access to Gmail YouTube Google
Suite Google search Chrome and the
complete Android ecosystem so what
happens when the CEO of Tesla now has
access to Twitter's facilities a
powerful ecosystem Elon musk's Hardware
companies now have access to Twitter's
social media networking capabilities and
since he typically funds businesses with
businesses we can't wait to see how he
actually utilizes this platform in his
company's favor think that video was
cool here are two more videos you'll
definitely enjoy